welcome to this video this is coverage
for the third round of the Norway chess
tournament and today probably has been
the the most uninteresting round yet
very interesting games and not so easy
to to actually choose the game of the
day yeah maybe it was easy I don't know
it was it was at least a day with more
than one really interesting game okay
let's see what happens starting with
swidler tupelov I go briefly through all
games or 24 games one a bit more
detailed swill at the part of this I
must be honest was the least exciting
game of today's round we got on this
somewhat strange line in the sicilian
Raftery 597 we basically now in a French
with white having yeah somewhat we get
extra move a for this is the move given
to white which is probably not very
helpful young and down it at the end we
had some trades here in this typical
French structure yeah what's move a for
its really not useful at all until after
a while we got a position I thought wear
white should be very very slightly
better if we look at this the pawn on d5
bishop wants is sick they are not ideal
probably it's not enough to ever get
anything serious going but was this a
slight edge yeah I would like defended
actively at the end they had a weekend
claim we're also Spiller could have
taken the pawn here to get to this but
this is not this is drawn or just the
drawn lot only on this level I mean not
very difficult to her word
they are not a very exciting game of a
technical game on probably worth looking
at a bit more if you have the time but
there are other games too to look at
here in this round next game is Grecian
our own young and this is a funny game I
can tell you right away that this is the
game which really made me love ok we
have a an English opening the máquina
variation with e for that's a very
interesting line for wide actually and
one reason why this move on a night f6e
six against thee for isn't so popular
anymore why term has some some decent
chances to emerge with an initiative in
this line and this is in fact the main
line that we would be got here we see
that white has a good Center which is
normally attacked by e5 here played by
room near Knight f3 I think this moves
knight c6 is a bit uncommon black
normally just takes on deform there are
various lines after this Bishop g5 is
one but very often we also get you also
get this this type of chair position
where white is just very slightly more
comfortable with nothing to remove
terribly dangerous yeah 96 is a bit
uncommon and we see that white is
gaining some time in the center black
retreat so he's playing on the fact that
this pawn structure is not ideal on the
other hand white has some development in
his favor of course H form yeah this is
protecting the bishop and has a second
idea 97 and Bishop d3 yeah and in this
position in this position it's a complex
move obviously and our only unplayed
efore after this move I
pretty much encourage you to pause the
video and and think for a moment what is
why it's best continuation here yeah
note that look at the clock clocks we
shook had already spent quite some time
before that well aronian was playing
quickly look at the position and try to
determine White's best continuation okay
so I'm going to tell you um the first
move was erm quite quite apparent I
guess h5 looks looks totally normal
attacking the Queen if it goes somewhere
here let's say now white just takes e4
is a pawn up grade center everything
fine aronian played Queen f5 still
playing quickly and now did you also see
the next move this move now is the one
that counts and Grisha played it look to
h4 this is a very funny move it he
detects eform yeah obviously and of
course it's it's a fork but what happens
this is not possible very easy yeah but
what happens after this move yeah you
care for it the queen is straight after
15 moves with rook h4 f4 f5 black screen
is falling yeah this is this is totally
funny yeah and what's also cute is what
are you doing here black can you do
something else let's say 95 for example
still taking Knight takes Queen e2 and
now rook takes e4 next is completely
destroying black I mean look at this
this is just a just an attack here with
with all pieces on the white side and
black ass nothing developed for example
if we can look at this
check yeah just just one possible line
which clearly shows like it sir it's
busted yeah in the game Aronian decided
to to give the Queen like that and here
why it is really just a queen up for
rook and for Luke and peace and with the
decent technique white should win yeah
and degree shock did a good job here and
never ever allowed anything special to
happen the main point is with material
up here open up the position in a way
that your king is not getting into any
danger and was alone Young probably
could have resigned earlier but okay why
not play on for a moment and see if the
other side is faltering richek is bound
to to come into time pressure no matter
what the position is Adam going to play
out the last couple moves here aronian
reside yeah just an opening disaster I
mean he played this very quickly it's
simply overlooking things what I find
between find a bit remarkable that him
played efore so quickly in this position
maybe it was some he confused something
in it some Buddhist preparation all I
know because obviously if all leads to a
crisis here I mean yeah if you overlook
age five Luke age for which you know but
she did obviously even if white is
playing something else it leads to a
total crisis like we need to let's say
yeah this is obviously a very sharp
position yeah this is play above wide
it's not bad or anything right just the
other thing is winning the Queen so it's
it's preferable but it's quite quite
interesting that you played this so
quickly because while you you need to I
don't know I know your level of
alertness should probably rise up in
this position but he still stumbled
right into the this trap losing the
Queen quite remarkable so greesh up with
that having two wins in a row he lost
this game quite quite quite quite yeah
badly with this time travel under but
after that two wins nice okay next game
is I think Giri chronic Greek Romanick
yeah we had a Catalan opening oh it's a
bit of a cheeky choice against chronic
him being the they are the person who
really brought the Catalan into the
limelight starting now yeah but let's
say ten years ago Rob that okay so we
have the main line absolute main line of
the Catalan here White has this choice a
for Queen takes e4 and a force maybe
there's somewhat more ambitious move it
leads to somewhat more complicated
positions yeah and this is a typical set
up that black off chooses against this a
4 set up he wants to establish c4 c4
before for a piece probably the night
and the compensation let's say I'm from
White's point of view is the better
central control white has some
weaknesses on the queenside but he has
good a good central controller sorry if
this was a bit too rial what what what
really surprised me is how how i give me
now is playing this is playing Bishop t2
I mean one idea of this move is probably
that this now is punished but still it
looks like a strange move to me yeah to
be honest this is leading the whole
thing here the whole opening its leading
to a and fantastically complex middle
game that is difficult to to really look
at with very little time the main point
is that chronic here played f5 very
ambitious move but probably a probably a
good move black is some getting some
some sort of space Atlanta chip quite
uncommon in the Catalan but white has
chosen a somewhat somewhat strange setup
I mean it does not look very ammonius
if we look at the position some moves
further we see that chronic is
completely concentrating his forces on
the kingside he's got the the f fire
with with double drugs Bishop's also
pointing towards the Kings and so black
has all yeah all pointed to white skin
and we see that he also is giving up a
pawn in the process for setting up this
this really active position um it's not
totally clear to me how to assess this
computers like white I mean they they
simply say probably okay upon and I
don't really see how i'm getting mated
um i am not so sure really if the
computers assessment so here is correct
i mean blacks play is is at least super
dangerous as it's much easier to be
black hear you you know what to tell you
want to yeah concentrate your pieces
near the king and night is already here
and you know just need the bishop to get
into the play and chromium after a few
more moves if we just continue a bit
yeah here it gets really tricky ideas
like Bishop f5 Queenie six attacking h3
the d file and it's really amazing duty
relatively quickly now um gallons into
into a lost position clap it's it's
happening around here I need to look at
my notes because it wasn't easy here
move 41 very often a problematic new it
seems that after Queenie to at least
this is what what Houdini is some is is
telling me that this should lead to to
an unclear position or let's say it says
about equal I call it unclear because
for humans it is not really looking like
an equal position maybe it's dynamically
equal
yeah not at all easy to play it's not
like a draw end game or anything um the
thing is right does not have many moves
he played this one and it seems that
this immediately needs leads to huge
problems and the the problematic move is
going to e6 this is setting up this
massive pressure against h3 but also and
this is the more problematic thing is
threatening Queen to be three and note
that white's back rank is also quite
weak if it was black smooth let's say
why this doing it nothing move this is
very problematic a bush Bishop h3 is
even stronger here after this yeah check
check check mate very very nice
checkmate yeah there are all kinds of
threats based on the week back rank and
always this knight on f3 if reverser
just completely ignoring everything so
so not really great um yeah after
queenie 6cm it gets very very
problematic white played Queenie too and
in this position actually chrome nick is
not playing the most precise move he
played g6 this probably preserves some
advantage but he could have taken here
immediately and this would have won
quite convincingly this type of position
the problem is if why does playing any
of any non check move yet that's hard to
play any non check move really let's say
this yeah the problem is that this is
happening and Bishop f3 will finish
right off look h1 made or you will lose
the Queen it's just a deadly attack so
something that just needs to be played
and after Bishop f5 blackest is really a
quite quite easily winning this is some
check the case
and point the problem being that Bishop
before is still fantastically great move
meet ya and this is also made next move
so I'm very very difficult to to to play
this position as white it is it is lost
by now um but chronic didn't take you
played g6 and after that it seems that
Bishop takes f3 is at least not losing
immediately it looks it looks very very
problematic but exactly this does not
seem to lose out right at least this is
the engine evaluation the thing is the
next best move is some maybe I still
should look at it a bit more because at
first I thought isn't this still a win
but funny enough it isn't I thought
Bishop g2 and rook d 1 h1 isn't the
Stila made or something the problem is
white always has this kind of defensive
tribe and while of course black is
better it's not totally clear that he's
willing easily in the game just to
compare things there was rook c4 plate
and after Bishop e3 there was simply
resignation yes there is absolutely a no
move here that can be played after rook
takes you four for example is taking and
going here with Queen h3 coming or
alternatively Candace check
quite easy yeah and what else is there I
mean what what what move should should
white play we can look at let's say play
something like that after that black and
black can take here check yet here for
example can just do that yeah black has
a very nice winning plan and not there
to h3 and then Bishop g2 made let's say
something like that yeah can you do it
know what this was a bit but weird and
say there are some lines where you can
actually allow the allow the promotion
let's say a 5g five I need to do it like
that b5 and now h4 yeah this is this is
the way to do it check me and the
meeting quite nice yeah so a win for
Chrome neck I think a really interesting
interesting middle game where he had
this initiative brewing on the Kings
side and it was certainly much easier
for black to play them for white even if
you can find some sort of improvement
with with computer assistance this is
just a terribly difficult position to
play for wide so i think a good wind for
chronic okay the next game is yeah you
would have expected that Carlton Clara
wanna being the top game on paper kawana
being the leader of the tournament after
two wins and the world champion would be
the game of the day it isn't i went for
kayaking augustine actor stein um but
let's do cara cara wanna first the
problem with this is it is very
difficult at the end and with my time
limited i cannot really tell the exact
thing I mean I cannot really tell you
and what exactly happened there I will
show you the game um every year this
kind of funny anti gruene felt really
got into into fashion in recent years
why does playing with a quick long
castle sometimes really playing for this
kind of crude H rylatech but on the
other hand it's also very interesting
strategically as white has brewed up
this typical gruenfelder but with more
pieces on the board that in the gruene
fraud we're always on c3 the night
exists is exchanged I don't want to do a
bigger theoretical overview here um I
will just say that this has been played
before all this to Quincy one um there
were games by kawana earlier games for
example against galfond in 2013 or
against Rome yarn in 2012 in both of
those games queen e one was Ben was
played and Quincy one here is a newer
move um not a novelty but a newer IDM
and this is at least two according to my
database the novelty h4 has been played
before in a game um and also Bishop f4
I'm sorry h4h 46 Bishop g5 or a ch-46
Bishop f4 SB play Bishop age 6 is new
yeah let's see what happened couple of
moves later because I was quite
surprised after if five and the next
couple of moves if we look at this
around here I thought that that council
should have a substantial advantage
really if you look at this he pushed the
night back in theaters just thought
Queen III yeah and you need to believe
me this was my idea without engine
assistance and the engine actually it
gives between g5 sorry
deleted first queen g5f six Queen III
but I really thought that this should be
right because now the Seaport cannot
move SB six is hanging so Queenie three
sm is some a good strategical move with
a with a technical point that c6 the
free move is not possible and the dark
squares and in blacks can do not look
too great if we look at those squares
see if I've before and so on not not too
exciting I'd well always have it in
green can I do it in rat rattus nice all
right those are those squares are a bit
a bit tricky and here's near white
should be somewhat better also nights
are good a nicely placed on c3 and d3
yeah Townsend played h5 and after those
moves black got in c6 and he's now
getting rid of the the week porn here
now very quickly the game enters the
crisis white opens up with f4 and right
here after default place Queen a three
honey funny move using this this pinning
business here and after a five-year here
that here's a critical point white could
have played 95 after which yeah maybe
black is somewhat more comfortable
slightly more comfortable he decided to
ever to sacrifice a piece on b5 and we
get got to this possession position
White has two pawns for the peace and we
have a queen trade this was certainly a
anticipated by cars but here um really
care awana has some has a very good
position it's it's a piece and it's not
totally clear how white white should
draw this funny transformation now with
this fork Chan so we had to this
position now a very very complicated
endgame white having three pawns sounds
nice but very often the pieces is
stronger as it can help to pick up some
of those extra pounds and what I'm what
I was referring to when I started the
first up late are the first moves of
this game is I cannot tell you in the
upcoming endgame if Kara wanna could
have won this um so I'm bit a bit
spoiling the result it ended in a draw
at the end yeah and I'm cannot I don't
really know if if he could have won um
my gut feeling is really telling me okay
there must be some sort of wind but it's
not like it's easily shown by the
computer arm I know or I have a great
idea myself and white always maintains a
some activity and the black hand of
course easily player lang check me into
those kind of traps yeah at the very
least he managed to to activate him and
I really don't know and it really should
be a win somehow no but it's not it's
really not easy I mean I'm really sure
that that there is no totally simple win
I'm a pretty sure of that um for example
here here there is an interesting
possibility after this may be age six is
a move intending to play look to g5 and
then regroup this but is it winning yeah
well look at night and against troop is
a draw and if white manages to exchange
the kingside yeah G&H pawn against the
h-bomb there's only two against one here
on the queenside I really
not sure if this I mean this looks like
serious winning winning chances but
still it's not totally clear to me in in
the game cousin got the beep horn
rolling check now the B porn got got
into action and then hacked he could
also sacrifice the G porn for the
activity and hear the engine already
shows it as being 000 the B porn is is
giving another counter play even with
the piece down yeah i'm going through
all this really quickly the thing is
this easily could have warranted a
deeper analysis for the game of the day
but believe me if you see the kayak
Enochs lying game you you have probably
you will understand why i went for this
for this game instead tough choice I
mean this was interesting from an end
game point of view but the other game to
be honest was so insane I needed to
needed to select this yeah here after
you come chan and a couple of more
checks they agree to a draw there is
there is nothing nothing to be done King
e5 wasn't played I'm pretty sure this
was the they put the Kings in the middle
to to signal the draw even this is a
draw of course but why would he allow
y2y to promote um yeah this was of
course a very important game for the
general standings if kawada had won this
it would have been obviously yeah
fantastic but still he has two wins in
the back already from the first rounds
and cards and yet to win a game so no
it's still still I guess um a good
result for piranha he probably will be
disappointed considering the way it it
was played out but okay so kayaking acha
style and you're probably curious okay
let's see we have
defense the the so-called steinitz
variation nowadays on top level if the
French is played it's normally this kind
of this line not Bishop before in fact
this is some a line that has a pretty
good theoretical standing at the moment
after Bishop e3 black has a number of
interesting options and the one that the
black player here chooses is a very
forcing one taking and Queen B 6 this is
in fact the line where i am not an
expert but where I know that white had
some problems in in recent times to
prove anything one thing is white has a
hard time not to sacrifice the B to pawn
it some it's basically impossible to
play I mean you can this kind of stuff
it's really not doing anything again go
here this is just too passive sometimes
you can play a 3-2 to save those kind of
pawns yeah as this is not a particularly
great idea but the critical line is
Queen d2 as it is so often sacrificing
the pawn and black is taking it yeah so
Black has snatched a pawn but what's
very important he has this counter play
coming we have a very forcing sequence
here which looks a bit weird at first
but this has been played a number of
times and this actually believed to be
okay for black yeah we went ear g3 was a
novelty by kayaking by the way and
starting here this game is as getting
really really tense it starts with King
d2 yeah this is I guess an
understandable move white wants to use
his rook he cannot castle obviously and
what is also whites main point is he
wants to prevent black
from castling the material situation is
equal long-term black has the bishop
pair and a good structure what white has
he has the activity and he wants to make
sure black is not getting the King out
of the center and he's really willing to
do a yeah to do some things for that
rugby one Bishop c6 and here we come to
the point should white retreat know what
kind of move what kinds of news are
there let's say root behavior for
example black world trade and castle and
it's not clear that white has anything
at all now it's some also this kind of
idea quite often this is not really
putting lots of pressure on black so
kayaking went for Bishop c5 he just
sacrificed the exchange establishing
this fantastic Bishop of C on c5
preventing black from canceling yeah
black took it yeah there is really no
point in not doing that so he took it
and rook c8 I guess fairly logical Musab
c8 it introduces this idea and it's
basically also the the only move that
that makes makes any great sense and now
this is already a very tense position
what what should why do there is a
number there are a number of options
that white contrive an interesting
before example is night to e4 looks
crazy at first but interesting takes 24
and why do you threatening this really
big check on d 7 which is a major he's
not just a check the problem is Black
has counter play with this check check
and this is preventing the mentioned
Queen D cell mate chat wyd can hear Jack
and go for a perpetual check but not
more that if four is a spectacular move
but it's not working I think this idea
also brought kayaking to to play the
upcoming movie played keen to see one
yeah this is going out of Queen G to
check which I just showed and it sent
sets black a very difficult problem what
to move White has a number of threats
one thread is king be too really that
slow King bee to getting out of this
check as well yeah Queen have one check
and then Queen D for a for ya quindi fo
fo would be checkmate and it's very
tough for black to learn to do anything
against that this thread is really
strong um sometimes you can even play
greedy for immediately if if black plays
that for example after Queen D for black
just resins the game between a4 is over
it is very very tricky now what should
like do he played the move f6 this is
the best move by far and overall the
quality of this game is fantastically hi
I think I mean if you sit there with
with your coffee and switch on a
computer I and that tells you all kinds
of things it's nice but they played
really excellently well I must say okay
after f6 what is what is happening if
white goes for the direct attack with
Queen a4 there is Queen f1 check this is
the counter play already mentioned this
is check check adhere black can play
Quincy form to prevent Queen a form
so Queen deform is not winning what
about King between if we try to prepare
or that getting out of the checks
exactly then Black has Luke c7 you know
this says it saves the day after you
create there's King f7 and this is the
motivation between the f6 move amongst
others but this is the main the main
point of it that you can actually get
the King out of it this position is not
it's not clear or white has an excellent
compensation but it's not totally clear
how it should end the computer is giving
it a 000 finding some sort of Perpetual
but ok this still would have been
interesting to to the app to to be
played out over the board one possible
line just to show a sample jack is this
yeah look some very problematic at first
but boom and a check check yeah and
around here we get to a point where one
of the sites will be favorable will give
a perpetual takes for example Queen d2
fantastic move ignoring the whole thing
here but it's black sets up a perpetual
himself yeah white white can also check
here this is not advisable check but
King age six is securing the draw FG
seven and now Magnus give the perpetual
super sharp super sharp position so this
was King be too yeah I can look at you
can look at akkad moosie a rook g7 also
interesting why not take the pawn yeah
there's Queen age six gaining gaining a
temple rook be certain groups e7 again
this defense and here for example the
move or the line takes takes takes am
King f7 seems to be about equal funny
yeah for example just to show this year
for example can be played we near three
and now queen dee 5s it is an enormous
idea and black has really no way to
prevent that it's again a perpetual
something along these lines check check
and the draw very complicated I think
actually that kayak hands move is the
best one it just puts the most pressure
on black and he's playing again a boom
move just takes on d5 what's the point
of the smooth yeah black takes it's
pretty much the only move and now why it
has an excellent continuation he plays
Queenie too and this is the most the
most fighting move white also could have
taken on f6 but this is a pretty
straightforward draw yeah why is it
pretty straight forward on Luke c7 as
being played and after this check can
you get to this funny situation with
white being close to promoting the porn
after the bishop t6 um takes takes a
here i can even promote check with this
probably like has something better yeah
after epsilon it's their better defense
a bishop 26 is probably ok but you can
also take here and just allow y to
promote yeah the the movie plate instead
of taking is just putting more pressure
on like he played thus the really strong
Queenie to this is setting up the threat
of capturing now Luke c7 was played
and yeah here there was also the
possibility to again just take also
after the trade if white no takes we get
the same position that we had seen
before with a draw being the result with
perpetual from one side but ki can
really wanted to win this and he played
it yet he tried to really play his hand
to the to the ad most he now played e6 I
think it's just very strong play yeah
why does a rook down it's a it's a full
rook but what's the point he wants to
play Queen a6 Queen c6 inmate black and
this is a very very substantial threat
the queen is also still covering
everyone so you can safely capture so
there's no counter play with the Queen
check here by the black and the funny
thing is what at steinmauer place is to
absolutely only move everything else
will lose played Bishop b6 you simply
must give up this Bishop here just
putting it on pre to after Bishop b6
which is also for what the only move to
Castle likely I'll castling on move 27
this is the kind of situations where you
where you check on your on your score
she that you actually allow to castle as
my Ruca moved on h8 has my king moved no
blacks King has not moved it hasn't
moved a lot in the variations you had in
your in your head but it's not really
happened on the board so you can castle
very funny yeah and now the direct
follow-up is pretty clear e 7 rook e8
must be played and Bishop game so it's
it's really crazy this bishop has gone
this funny journey now to d8 in order to
cover the the the lonesome warrior only
seven and that has been pushed all the
way into into blacks camp and black is
just about holding this in six square
I played Quincy 8 getting the Queen back
and also covering e6 how to assess this
position hmm very very difficult um I
actually think the most likely outcome
is a draw if we if we let's say let's
get it out arrows if we look at this
kind of configuration the rook against
the pawn of the bishop this basically
cancels each other out White's Bishop
and pawn simply totally killed the rook
it cannot do much so and it's happiness
of course a very strong passport always
one one step on ya to promotion um so I
really don't see any side winning this
but kayaking is trying hard I can tell
you he's trying hard he am activated ya
hear ya Queen trade is very welcome now
if black will trade the Queen you can
easily get into big trouble if we look
at this there is a quick phone and
merging on the queenside black does not
want to trade queens and now kayak a
nice or is using his King just advanced
in here on the queenside in the meantime
I Christine actor Stein is going for
counter play with age for this is a
really strong play he gets his rook
suddenly active probably on age four and
this is the only way also to activate
the look he found that the way to play
his position in the most active way
possible and yeah now we are close to
the to the time control on move on move
40 and right here the game enters yet
another yet another crisis a 4 plate
yeah covers covers be five so that white
and green can actually move here
um and now acts time up the Steiners
plane g5 yeah and here exactly here on
we we see I think this is kai Atkins
only mistake in the game it's a severe
one but ok the whole the whole position
and the whole game is obviously very
tough to play he now took on in the
sorry he played Queen d3 that was the
mistake he should have taken on g5 and
it seems that this leads to list this
leads to a draw he probably has
overlooked something when he played
queen d 3 wire should this lead to a
draw we can look at can you get in line
um Quincy five check rook takes a key
King take sorry and then yeah this kind
of Perpetual is happening black really
am has no way to to avoid that maybe he
still wanted to try to win with Queen d3
but it is really not materializing black
now took on f4 and no this was played
may be here he had some here thought
that this was good but black has the
good move f3 and this is helping him
immensely this is much better than that
then some what they are more passive
movement for example black also could
have thought about king queen d6 after
that white has the funny defense yeah
like that with with a queen sec it
probably is ultimately insufficient but
f3 is just stronger white must take that
there is really no no other mousse and
then Queenie six and now blackest is
nicely coordinated the Queen and King
stopped the e porn and g4 will fall g5
plate Queen g6 yeah note the maid threat
very important yeah g6 check and the
king went back yeah the only the only
counter play with with g7 here it's it's
a bit a bit of a desperation attempt but
here think King f7 was more precise
after that I really don't see any move
for white he didn't play that but after
this I think black just just grabs the
material here this moves that artist I'm
plate should win the game it's also also
win yeah why promoted and now try it for
some last hope counter player with the
Queen yeah it looks strange oops sorry
Cathy sir we should be six look strange
to give up the pawn but there really is
there really is nothing that you can do
black your system again coming with the
rook trying to to attack the White King
okay yeah we got this end game here yeah
like being an exchange up and he has
this this strong passer it it is a
window this
game have formed a five but here exactly
here in this position we see the black
players only real big mistake after this
really fantastic fight he now played the
move f3 and this is unfortunately for
him spoiling the win the thing is it
seems that what black needs to do is
quickly try to mop up both pawns then
sacrifice a look for the apron um this
basically what happened in the game but
f3 seems to lose a temple because it
does not get both pawns if black plays
rook G to our king g 6 is also possible
let's do king e cigs for example this
would have won yeah well let's say come
on let's not do this this is the easiest
come on rook g2 king be seven and now
black actually manages to take both
pawns if we look at this this is
important and now black gets in deform
and the f pawn moves to win the game
there is no defense against this Y term
if we look at this white cannot really
save anything if he tries to do this for
example this is just far too quick yep
and at the end of the deep on decides
about the king is taking care of the
edge calm the F point here moving this
now is it seems us absolutely not
essential King be seven and now we see
it's quite similar but the f porn now
this move has been lost so white
couldn't take on h2 so we get a very
comparable endgame but with an H pawn
and this is in fact the wrong
white skin is approaching the deep own
but the bishop is stopping the f porn
yeah a fantastic fantastic struggle
really kayaking for very long time tried
the absolute utmost to win the game
always trying to to sharpen up things
but at the stein put up a great defense
really great and here was very close to
win I mean this was all very strong play
also this is h5 using the rook on the H
file was just a very very good game I
think by both sides and one of those
calculation errors they simply they
simply occur in such a complicated game
also note that while you're sitting
there for hours and it simply tires you
two to have this this wild stuff to be
calculated all the time so yeah it's a
certainly um would have been grateful
for i decided to win the game of course
but i think it would be a would be
really am yeah unwise to be a to be
totally disappointed by this performance
it was really a great fight and very
enjoyable for the spectators yeah i hope
you enjoyed the coverage of this round
wasn't so so easy to select the kawana
Carson karana game also was was very
interesting this end game also deserves
some closer examination but I decided
for this because was such a nice very
very yum yum um like in the word him now
yeah two-sided is probably a wrong wrong
wrong but it was a fight on we're both
sides really did a great job I mean it
was not a very one-sided game okay i
hope you enjoyed it thanks for watching
and then the next round actually is only
played on saturday yeah so there's no
round on friday friday the
the six on only on saturdays haven't
they will continue to play so don't
wonder if there's no game tomorrow
uploaded or no video uploaded thanks for
watching